[Music]
it's time now to see what's making the
headlines with the director of the demos
think tank polly mckenzie and the pr
consultant alex dean they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the financial times pictures floral
tributes for the 19 children killed in a
school shooting in texas as police there
face growing anger over their response
to the attack
the telegraph says a conservative mp son
is a fighting with ukrainian soldiers
and helped save a fellow britain maimed
by a landmine
the guardian reports on the prime
minister's changes to the ministerial
code which mean ministers won't need to
resign if court breaking rules
triggering accusations the changes were
made to protect his job ahead of a new
partygate inquiry
the mirror has word of the queen's
platinum jubilee plans set to include
prince charles prince william and prince
george with the paper calling heirs to
the future
the express says families setting off
for half term holidays face chaos at
airports today and are set for worse
this summer due to staff shortages
and the star has the same story on its
front page
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by the
director of the demos think tank polly
mckenzie and the pr consultant alex dean
welcome to both of you let's start with
the ft weekend their front page um
and having a look at the awful story in
texas
the
shooting the rob elementary school today
we've been having responses from those
that responded iv police
and actually just putting their hands up
and said they got it awfully wrong alex
that's right and i may i make the first
point this is the only
appearance of this story on any of the
front pages that we've seen for tomorrow
how swiftly it seems we move on from
these tragedies in the united states
perhaps because lamentably they happen
so often
as you say the police have completely
conceded that they
got this terribly wrong with regard to
this school and what they did was to
arrive at the scene circle the school
prevent anyone else going in and then
let the shooter go ahead killing people
to his heart's content i mean i know
that the police do an incredibly hard
job in their country as well as ours
perhaps given the plethora of guns on
the streets and in people's hands uh an
even harder job than the police here in
the united kingdom but i don't think it
took a genius to work out that they took
the wrong approach on this yes polly
yeah i mean it's absolutely
heartbreaking um
to read the timeline you know you've got
one on the sky website everywhere you go
through what the police have set out
and they
just waited
while a child in that classroom was
calling 9-1-1
telling them updating them what was
happening
asking for help
and help was there it was just the other
side of the door
and and that's just extraordinary to me
and devastating
and you know i think it's very difficult
for us in the united kingdom to
understand
the debate and the culture around this
in the united states because we we just
don't have the same discourse about guns
this is a problem which only happens in
america there are violent angry
teenagers in every country in the world
but it's only in america that school
shootings mass public shootings are
happen
you know regularly
this within this month that we were
talking about a shooting at a
convenience store it's because anybody
pretty much can get hold of an assault
rifle and and to to sit to read one of
these stories
and not feel that
urgent desperate need to do something
that could have stopped this
regardless of the police failing some
things that would have stopped this
angry young man getting hold of those
two assault rifles and 1600 rounds of
ammunition he took into that school
it's you know and if the us is going to
have a gun culture like that the story
they tell
is it's fine because we need good guys
with guns as well
but you know in this example the good
guys with the guns were useless
i think it's it's a reminder that that
idea that if you just arm everybody you
can prevent shootings is just
self-evidently not true
let's move on to the guardian um
completely different story as you said
that was the only paper that has
the shootings in texas on the front page
but let's move to the guardian uh and
this is to do with the prime minister um
the accusation is that he's changing
the code to
protect his position as he's facing
another
inquiry alex
well of course
it's completely untrue there is a
committee that has produced a report
that recommends changes to the way the
ministerial code is implemented and some
people have worked themselves up into an
absolute froth today over this story
because they think that boris you know
controls uh this and has somehow been
able to
get the former head of mi5 and the
queen's former uh permanent private
secretary um to do exactly what he
wishes and then to enable him to
bend or break the rules so you're
suggesting it's just bad timing
well no no
it is plain that the ministerial cade
has been under review for some time and
this committee has been looking at what
happens with the ministerial code but
the most important thing for people to
understand is if you have willfully
misled the house of commons under the
change that this co
new code suggests you still resign
so people who have been seeking to
suggest that this is a way for boris to
save his skin and to manipulate things
and he's changed the rules are doubly
wrong first of all it's not the prime
minister who's changed the rules or if
this goes through and second of all
under the new rules if you willfully
mislead the house of commons you go to
so so i mean as i say some people
include some very senior labour
politicians who want to know better have
been saying things online and interviews
today which are completely inaccurate
um polly is that your take on on this
i think alex is both completely right
and completely wrong
there is
you know a lot of the commentary here is
overblown the changes are relatively
small
and this question of kind of
saying that ministers don't always have
to resign if they've broken the code
they can have other punishments which
lots of people got very upset about has
always kind of been the principle and
it's just it's codified and some of
these changes have as alex says been
recommended by uh by a sort of separate
committee however i think there is a a
problem here
one is that the prime minister has
bulked at the idea of actually giving
the independent adviser the right to
initiate an investigation
the prime minister will still
essentially have a veto against that i
think that that is very unfortunate and
i also think there's you know the
reality is we have had breaches of the
ministerial code uh in which the prime
minister has sought no sanction
whatsoever uh for example with with
pretty patel who uh was found to have
breached the ministerial code and the
prime minister said
oh well
for me
you know there's something about the the
forward right so the prime minister most
of the ministerial code is extremely
boring legalistic tone there's a little
bit at the beginning which is you know
like real prose and in the prime
minister's new one it just sort of says
the code's fine it's been operating for
30 years i had the privilege to be
involved in writing
i mean tiny tiny
review of the draft of david cameron's
first ministerial code and in that he
said we promise to be different he said
that we had an obligation to be
different to do better than before
and that aspiration
to build trust and confidence with high
standards of propriety and ethics is
something that unfortunately i do think
is completely absent from this
government under boris johnson's
leadership right and just to
make a summary there of that do you
believe that the the new code is a
weakening of the system
just very briefly yes or no at the
moment yes but the problem is that the
premise is not interested in actually
enforcing any rules of conduct or
propriety in downing street amongst his
ministerial team he's in general he's
looking for ways to regul out of things
just come back alex very quickly
i know that perhaps some people would
like that to be the conclusion this is a
dilution of the code but polly's
strongest point in my view is that one
about the independent investigators not
being able to trigger um independent
reviews and i say uh or of his or her
own bat
i completely agree with that but the
point is that's the status quo the prime
minister hasn't changed that at all so
people were getting worked up about that
as well are triply wrong
right just very quickly uh we've got
time to go to the ft and the cost of
living crisis 15 billion uh boris
johnson claiming that that will not feed
inflation polly
well i mean so part of this is about
whether it counts actually as uh
spending uh or whether it's just a
rebate and therefore is sort of
discounted against inflation rates in
our gas bills
um but you know crucially it's
absolutely essential if the government
is worried about inflation there are
monetary and fiscal policy changes that
they could make um and i think it's
absolutely essential for families i was
really i was impressed actually by the
scale and the ambition and the and the
focus
that um that they that they unleashed um
yesterday and frankly this is what we
should have seen in the spring statement
uh in 30 seconds i'm guessing you're
agreeing with that alex says you're
nodding your head i think it's a great i
think it's a great package i agree with
the chief economist of from goldman
sachs who's created on the front of the
ft saying this is probably going to
avert a recession or mean we have a very
mild one i note that he was of course
economic advisor to the last chancellor
say he knows a little about that where
off he speaks i think this is a good
package that people in this country
really need i applaud it okay alex and
polly for the moment thank you coming up
the daily star says families trying to
get away ahead of the summer break have
faced chaos on the roads and at the
airports more on that come back to us
[Music]
[Music]
you